hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel I have a buck 110 some
cinder blocks and a baby sledge and
we're gonna find out exactly how tough
this knife is guys I'm really excited to
do this video cuz I have a lot of fond
memories of buck knives like a lot of
you guys a buck knife was my first real
knife so let me show you this brand new
buck 110 comes with this leather sheath
and look at that isn't that beautiful
mmm crisp firm action on that just fits
in the hand very nicely it's a large
pocket knife one thing I really like
about the buck 110 is its classic look
you know the brass and the wood handle
it seems like every single knife on the
market nowadays is a tactical pocket
knife you know I'm not a member of SEAL
team 6 I'm not going to be stabbing
terrorists with this I don't see a point
in pretending it's a military weapon now
the buck 110 is a lock blade pocket
knife you open it up and it clicks into
place and then it's locked it will not
unfold until you hit the button there on
the back one way to judge the
craftsmanship of a pocket knife is how
much play there is in the blade and
these buck knives up and down there is
zero play you cannot wiggle that at all
side to side just ever so slightly you
can detect a little bit of play but very
very little this thing is put together
extremely well now the buck knife comes
straight from the factory razor-sharp
look at this
getting a little close to my fingers
there oh great now you're gonna pick up
all this paper well there's been a lot
of yakety-yak in this video now it's
time to test how durable the buck 110
really is and the first thing we're
gonna test is this ability to maintain a
sharp edge now I already showed you how
sharp it is coming out of the box let's
see how well it can hold that edge I'm
gonna make a big pile of shavings here
and then we're gonna do the paper test
and see if it maintains that razor-sharp
edge cutting up these wood shavings was
so easy with this knife it absolutely
chewed through this wood like a chainsaw
and now let's see how much of an edge it
still has well guys that knife is still
razor-sharp and that's what buck knives
are known for maintaining a sharp edge
even under extreme abuse and they do
this by using high-quality steel and
then hardening it correctly which can be
quite complicated and time-consuming and
these guys have got it down to a science
they've been doing this for over a
hundred years well we know the buck
knife can hold an edge but let's see how
durable it is alright so we've got a
number 10 can of garbanzo beans here and
I'm going to demonstrate another common
use for my favorite camp knives you know
the can opener was invented 50 years
after the invention of the tin can so
back then you wanted to open it up you
did it this way
there you go cut through the tin can
like butter alright got these chunks of
cinder blocks here you got my baby
sledge we're gonna find out exactly how
tough this edge is look at that let's
see what else we can do
look at that got the sword and the stone
here going oh look at that guys look at
the top of the blade there's no
mushrooming no dents no major scratches
from hitting it with a baby sledge well
that definitely put some Nicks in the
blade but that was pretty awesome that
thing cut into a cinderblock the knife
was literally stuck in the cinderblock
there for a little bit that was pretty
cool that definitely affected the
sharpness all right let's split some
kindling here okay
oh this is so bad to do with the pocket
knife
Oh busted off the lock mechanism that
little piece of metal that goes right
there just bust it off it's probably
laying around down here somewhere
there we go I gotta tell you I'm really
sad to see this knife get broken is a
great knife but I can tell you from
years of experience breaking pocket
knives that there are a couple really
great ways to jack up a pocketknife
first off holding it and trying to split
wood by beating the back of it like you
saw me do that's not good
most the time if you're use smaller
pieces of wood it won't break the metal
but it'll get progressively more and
more wiggle in the blade until it
doesn't lock properly it wears down the
locking mechanism really fast
the second way it's you can break pocket
knives very easily is by throwing them
when I was a kid I did that with my
first buck knife and I put that blade
point first into the ground and there
was a rock under there they hit that
rock and broke off about a sixteenth of
an inch off the tip of my knife well
guys I hope you enjoyed this video and
learned something new if you want to see
more great videos from the outdoor boy's
YouTube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe we put out new videos every
week thanks for watching we hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you'd like to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boy's YouTube channel don't forget to
click Subscribe we put out new videos
every week and don't forget to hit that
Bell button so you'll get notified when
we put out another great video